REPORTING.>>, HANGN ON
AVE THE ER OF
WHU TELLE YOU  YOU'RHG U ON THEV
>> THANK YOU V FOR
DIRO T TRY.
FROHERE TTA
IA WHOENETRATE KYIWITH THAT SIT
K YOU,RTANT TOOF THE WHOLE WORLD
O SUPPORT US
SO FYO EVERYBOUNDERSTAND, PUTIDW
WHOL E SUKINPUTI
WHO IS WATCHING RIGHNOK THIS WA.
THEY OWANTRE
RETURN BACHEURN LY.UDR MY PRESI,
AM OF
MA AAS
HE JT SIMP CRAZY
JSIMPLY EVIL TOKILLAINIANIAN WO
KILLED JSTERDAY UNDER THE THN N
THAT'S EXACTLYHY WE SH
SUPPORT
UKRAMORROW
HAT ED SGREE YOU.
TTELLISUR PAR.Y NEED TWHICH  PE
PUTIN TOAYBSOLUTELY
IOR.EFIT NOWS TH AEAM 2.
TH
EFINITELY HELP
US.WE DEFY NEEDO BLOCANRUN PL TE
WEITEDO DO
EVERYTNGULD I CALL ON THWEO TOA.
AND THIS IS THE MAXIORHOALL RUS.
SITUATION
THING TO KEEP WORL. THING OUR
BY T WAYTHANK U., UK THE
AND I NTJAVELI
ANY SINGLEHOE
S.SSIATA
. P CANL HEAR ME, I WANT
RE.
YOU ARE IN CENTRAL KYIV RINOW,
FITIISTRICT HERE. MOMENT U.S.
RISK OF FALLINTO THE RUSSIE YOU?
ANS -- ME IS JUST A .RAID OF  H
THAT IN FIVEINE HAVEUS
.D WE HAVE A BOMB SHELTER 100
RETO T OURVBECAUS
THH
T YEARS.INST US
AND I TRD THE E H
OUATION IN UKRAI
WE UKRAINERE STAG
FROM THEK IN BREAD, FO
WE ARE SNDING IN LIN GIVE
RUSSN AGGRESSION. STAND AGA
CUPATION.
WE ARE UNID TOGETHER WITH OLE WR
THIADEE FORCES.
WEHAD WORD THERE'S BEE
OFFICIAL THE
GORNOR ARM
NS ANDTAILS.
ZO UAIT ?KE NO-FLY
ITELY.
WE SHODOE CAN.PRESIDT  SAY
AB AGAINST
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.ANFA
MOCRACY
AND DONST RUSSIAESON ANYEASO
PUTIN K OF US.M CAN.IS IDIRECT H
AD
ANLD
LY LIKIS HIS FU.D
>> MR. PRESIDENT, CAN YOU TELL
E WITHANIN
ISY EASY. SEE.
30 BATTALION
ANWEE MAORIADEFENS
MORER  IT.
IS THE LONG LE  TE THAT FOR TWO
TONLHE
BATT
ARMS FOR THAT.
S THEILY LIME SINGLE DEFENSE
EVERE
JOIN US.Y TOUCHABLD
GREAT DETRATION HOINIAN PEOPLE
HOW WE ARE AGAINST RUSSIAN
CLEAR.ION.
>> HOW LONG DO YOU THINK YOU CAN
I THINK R WILLVE
UKRAINE DESPITE -- NTT
HAS HE HREE PEOPLE THUR